aujourd'hui nous fêtons les henry donc
sortait lui une bonne blague pour qu'ils
henry selick patient soit moi cela c'est
la station reçoivent ou non je suis pas
sûr malheureusement c'est vous et
l'émission d'alex vous c'est même chose
là bas j'ai vu que la bande annonce ça
risque d'aller investir en ce moment là
il y en a eu une la semaine dernière oui
mais je leur avais un rack une aubergine
moussaka alors le berger l'espagne a way
eddie cascio cadeau dit attention va se
réveiller la tête dans le cumulus
oui ça s'est fait très peur comme ça un
peu peur quand on est dans cette
émission d'ailleurs je me pose souvent
la question quand on est invité qu'on
sait pourquoi on vient déjà veut on
revient parce que vous êtes déjà venu et
pourrissent est qu'on aime bien on est
content de les revoir
voilà un jour de ton petit cadeau pour
vous que eric et vous fera en vidéo dans
un petit pas pour l'homme un grand pas
pour l'humidité
ça c'est moi je me faisais payer c'est
tous les jours ou bien trouver les
moyens t'amuser donc je me creuser la
tête à dire comment je peux dire qu'il
fait pas beau de marc et voilà
[Musique]